if you were starting a YouTube channel
in 2024 what would you do one of the
biggest opportunities if you want to
succeed on YouTube is consolidating time
and saving people time here's what I
mean what if my first videos suck they
will your first videos will be your
worst videos you know you be terrible
but the recipe to get to success is suck
suck suckcess how do I write good titles
that's something to master how do I make
good thumbnails that get people to click
that's something to master but there's
something more important than all of
that so Sean if you were St stting a
YouTube channel in 2024 what would you
do especially considering that you've
been in the YouTube game for 17 years
now you've started multiple channels
three silver play buttons how would you
get started in this new year yeah so I
wrote down five things when I thought
about this question and the first one is
courage you have to start messy and I
think about this you know I have some
tactics as we get into it but now that
I've had the chance to coach so many
different people that have started
YouTube channels and grow their YouTube
channels I've realized that really the
first thing that holds us back is our
self and our fears and our mindsets we
feel like we're not ready we feel like
man is anybody going to care we feel
like am I going to be judged is there
going to be negative comments and these
are all legitimate mindsets but you're
not going to get results if you don't
start you're never going to know if you
don't start everything that you want in
life is outside of your comfort zone so
I do want to lay a foundation that um
you got to start before you're ready you
got to start messy you probably have a
million questions even if youve already
been subscribed to or the think media
podcast or other channel for a while you
still probably are like but what about
this but what about that you have to
just start and my second tip is Clarity
and we can hit that one in a second but
the reason that I say start messy is
there's really two kinds of people maybe
you're already a a professional a
business owner so you're already know
you're in real estate you already are in
carpentry and so you know like you're
going to start a DIY channel helping
people fix stuff around the home you
know that you're going to start a real
estate channel to get leads clients and
sales in your local community you know
you're a musician that uses Ableton so
you want to start doing music tutorials
like you already have Clarity so if you
have that we can dial that in when we
get there in a second but there's this
whole other category where you know
someone's listening to this they know
they want to start but they're unsure
they they have a million questions about
what Niche what topic what about this
what about that and I would encourage
you to just start posting videos just
try something don't overthink it because
we do learn by doing and I know for me
because I didn't have Fierce Clarity
when I started I just started posting
random videos on my Sean canell Channel
there's a million lessons of mistakes I
made but the benefit of that was I
started to learn how to film I was
learned how to edit I experimented with
this topic that topic and even though
the brand ended up being kind of not
great and the niche wasn't really clear
and I was all over the place and and
that wasn't my successful YouTube
channel I haven't even uploaded there in
years it was a personal development
experience a skill development
experience and I like to say I have four
YouTube channels that help me eventually
start a successful one so absolutely in
2024 start as soon as possible don't put
it off don't just watch YouTube videos
don't just consume information we learn
by doing take action press record you
got it takes courage you got to get
uncomfortable so just start so this is
one of the most common pieces of advice
that you give people is that they have
to just start and so it might sound like
the kind of thing that we just kind of
push the side like yeah yeah of course
Sean's going to say that but I would
just challenge everybody who's listening
to this like yeah but have you actually
done it yet because it is actually so
underrated that you just have to keep
doing it and keep doing it week after
week right Sean and so it's that showing
up every week even though you are afraid
or it hasn't been going as well so
continuous courage and so what is point
number two yeah so Point number two is
is Clarity and here's what I mean if
you've started and if you have maybe a
few things that are under your belt like
you're comfortable you figured out your
camera it may just be your smartphone
youve maybe figured out that you're
going to just edit videos simply on your
phone or use cap cut I love that as a
mobile video editor something like that
you maybe have shot a few videos so
you've overcome some hurdles and Camera
confidence Etc you know the title of
this talk is like if I was starting from
scratch what would I do so I thought
what we could do is we could look and
process a channel that I've always
dreamed of starting but as a dad with a
three-year-old one-year-old this video
podcast or other channel running the
company it's just a dream and it's on
the side and I got enough going on with
the niche I'm in but I think about you
want to get clear on what is the best
channel for you related to your passions
what is the best channel for you related
to things that will keep you curious ask
yourself will I still be interested
interested and Fascinate fascinated by
this and willing to research this and
loving to study this and read about it
like you don't have to be an expert but
if you're curious and you love it and
you're interested in it I think that's
the superpower um so I'm passionate
about it I'm I'm curious I would I geek
out on it it's a personal thing that I
like to research and study and would
love to share about and it's also a way
to make money now that's just making the
assumption that that would be the desire
how do I start a successful YouTube
channel in 2024 and a profitable YouTube
channel so the case study for me would
be I would start a channel on biohacking
in the health Niche focusing on maybe
neut Tropics which are like these brain
vitamins there's different sometimes it
might be in liquid form pill form um but
this kind of category would be in a way
ice baths red light therapy pmf mats
brain drugs neut Tropics all this
different stuff because that's also like
something I personally as an
entrepreneur that wants to be at high
performance something I also like I
don't know it's almost like a hobby and
I like to read about it and research it
and watch stuff so having Clarity for
The Listener what channel what topic
best fits at the intersection of your
passion your proficiency what keeps you
curious what you're good at what you put
some time on I don't know if I'm good at
biohacking but I've got a few years
under my belt I've got some knowledge
under my belt and one of the myths is
you have to be an expert I wouldn't even
call myself an expert I have some tips
to share that actually help when you're
not an expert and why you can still
create a great Channel but I am just a
little bit a few steps ahead of others
in that area I've read more about it
researched more about it I followed
people okay great and I'm also from
before I've even started the channel
identified like a business plan or a
money plan related to that and uh uh
what you call it profit passion
proficiency and profit and around profit
it's like I could do affiliate marketing
for the different products that I
personally purchase I've got red light
therapy panels on my wall I've got a
pemf mat I've got these um a a cupboard
full of liver and you know
glutathion and vitamin
D2 you know vitamin D plus K2 and I'm
drinking all kinds of like ginger shots
and comparing uh element electrolytes to
other electrolytes and how much sodium
magnesium and stuff so it's again I'm
personally into it and I love talking to
people who are experts which I could
interview and we can get back to that so
if we're talking about how do I start a
successful YouTube channel from scratch
one of the most underrated things is
getting your Niche right getting a your
topic right and don't let that be
confused with starting messy and don't
let that be confused nobody wants to
hear this but let's say you started a
YouTube channel wrong I think that's
still okay it never really worked you
did 50 to 100 videos one of the most
painful things could be pivoting your
Niche or starting a second Channel but
people make the mistake that a lot of
times that's what it takes to find
success there's a stat that says the
average successful entrepreneur that
like gets through the the dip of hard
work and getting cash flow and getting
startup happening and actually makes it
to some level of success and
sustainability has started 2.6
businesses so what does that mean they
have one successful business and out of
one to two that failed so what like on
average so any successful entrepreneur
business owner that now has a successful
business on average had at least one
fail or two fail before they found the
one that worked I think that could be
similar to YouTube as well and it may
not be that you actually have to have a
different Channel but I think that
should give you permission to like what
if my first video suck they will your
first videos will be your worst videos
you know it' be terrible but though you
know your way to get to success I heard
one person put it this way the recipe to
get to success is suck suck
suckcess your first three or 30 videos
might suck they might not be very good
but that's what leads to success so
start before you're ready then dial in
that Clarity and so that would be the
niche that I choose I I would pick that
Niche and I'll explain why in a little
bit but that would be tip number two get
clear on your Niche get clear on who
your Channel's for what problem does it
solve and get clear that again if you
want this to be financially viable come
up with a money plan come up with kind
of a business plan for your CH Channel
ahead of time to like start with the end
of Mind look down the road what is it
you want to build and start a channel
intelligently and strategically by
thinking through some of those things I
think it's key what you're saying about
the ability to Pivot that one out of
those three businesses ideas is the one
that takes off but there's two failed
ones in there because so many people ask
us like well I I have this channel
already and like I don't know what to do
with it so we're saying then don't do
that channel like if if follow all of
the advice advice listen to Sean Kel and
other experts and actually you know
don't be afraid to Pivot and to change
into um you know after you're taking in
all of this advice and so I think that
one is really key for a lot of people
listening because a lot of people are
going to need to Pivot after listening
to a lot of this training and so um that
takes us into Point number three yeah so
Point number three is create a schedule
you know what gets scheduled gets done
it's in a way also like create a system
for how you're going to be producing
content we don't rise to the level of
our goals we fall to the level of our
systems what's a system well I am
researching on this day I'm recording on
this day um it may be even things you
put into your life my aunt's going to
watch the kids Saturday morning so that
I can film um I'm going to edit here and
then eventually and there's a lot of
things more than we'll cover here but
you know then I take the SD card out it
goes to my computer the system is I use
this editing software and then I put it
in there and and I export the file and I
upload it um and ultimately you know one
of the most powerful things we've
created is not just a seven step system
for YouTube success I think media but
all but like probably a hundred Micro
Systems everything in life I think for a
life well lived that's effective and
productive is going to be empowered by
systems and so having a schedule is one
of those if you're going to start a
channel it's not enough to just start it
cuz technically to start a channel right
you just got to set it up but what what
we mean is like can we start a channel
that has some level of consistency on it
and I would
recommend um you know there's so many
different answers to this question but
it's like how many videos should I
upload a week I would recommend one
video a week and I would want to Define
that one thoughtful strategic quality
researched crafted video per week I
don't mean it has to be edited or
anything again you may be able to just
hit record talk for 7 minutes turn the
camera off off and upload it but for
that 7 minutes to be as powerful as
possible having a little practice having
a little planning um having some notes
in front of you thinking about what the
title is ahead of time thinking through
it prior planning prevents poor
performance and one of the biggest
opportunities if you want to succeed on
YouTube is consolidating time and saving
people time here's what I mean there's a
really successful personal finance
YouTuber named Graham stefen and one of
the things he's known for is he puts out
great researched videos that are concise
clear and they really take complex
information and they make it simple well
what does he do he's known for
researching 20 30 40 hours for one video
now I'm not saying you have to take that
much time to be successful but think
about what happens if he if he
researches and plans for 20 hours and
the final product of his video is 10
minutes it's one of the reasons why the
video is so successful because we're all
so busy in our lives you're doing the
heavy lifting again even if you don't
edit if you take an hour or 2 hours hour
or 3 hours to prepare and then all of
that time preparing you've Consolidated
it down into a 3 to 5 minute or a
13-minute video you're doing a service
to people that's why people feel the
value of it the the flip side is true if
you just wing it it kind of reminds me
of my first video I was like listen this
my first video um I'm not going to be
energetic or entertaining I don't even
have a plan and that video didn't go
viral like CU there was no plan there
was no energy I didn't really go into it
intentionally so one long form upload
per week to clarify I think that there's
it gets interesting with YouTube shorts
those are much easier to create it's
fine to start with YouTube shorts
there's going to be vertical video 60
seconds or less that maybe switches it
up so if you can do a long form video
and a couple shorts totally fine if you
have bandwidth for more great but I
think people are
underestimating committing to uploading
just one quality video and I've this is
what I mean by quality too I mean
content value not production value back
to not editing content value would be
you put your phone on some shoe boxes in
front of a window the there's carpet on
the floor and you're it's a smaller room
so just the on camera phone microphone
is good enough like so you have no
accessories no gear great and but people
can hear you they can see you you got
some daylight the production value is
not that impressive it's not a fancy
camera but the content value is the
title you thought about the topic you
know the audience car cares about
because of research and then the the
investment you've put in into the
information that you're sharing and so
um think about that content like high
quality content and I've heard it said
that the definition of Excellence is
doing the best you have with what you
have right now so Excellence is a
spectrum of course if you're not
comparing yourself to other people you
just want to beat your previous best if
you start messy if you have a decent
level of clarity of this is the
direction I'm going this is who my
channel is for what problem it's going
to solve and then you commit to once a
week a lot of things can happen momentum
happens you learn as you go you start
getting a feedback because you're
putting outputs out there um you're you
evaluate the results as you go and you
are continuing to approve we always say
get 1% better and there's something
powerful about the one video and long
form is your best path still to being
paid the most money from YouTube to I
believe having the deepest impact sure
shorts can attract a new audience and
they can spread and and and absolutely
do shorts but if like to me that's like
the foundational ethic like YouTube long
form and by definition of long form
would be over a minute but I'm say you
know five eight minutes 12 16 we get
wrapped up in those details just quality
how long should the video be and for me
back on my new Tropic biohacking Channel
I start thinking about okay what are the
opportunities which actually I think
that's a few future point but that would
be number three so so schedule if
Baseline upload one high effort based on
the resources you have and the time you
have video per week and commit to that
you're going to see crazy momentum over
the next year awesome so number five or
Point number four is that what we're on
is number yes Point number four that's
right okay so Point number four then is
topics I think that in 2024 one of the
biggest mistakes that people are making
is they're not knowing what matters most
on YouTube so let me actually go in
descending order of the things that and
how important they are people wonder how
important are YouTube tags not very
important let's put that in number five
okay how important is your YouTube
description kind of important you can
reinforce some words and data that might
communicate to YouTube what the video is
about also there's some practical things
there that could serve the viewer maybe
some links you could put in the
description that could lead to
monetization so description is probably
in the fourth place what's most
important with the videos okay in second
and third place I think it's a tie
people say what's most important is it
the thumbnail is it the title I would
say thumbnail is actually probably
second place because it's more important
than title you want a good th uh a good
thumbnail but you you literally can't
have one without the other like they
work together so I'd go third place most
important would be title second place
most important would be thumbnail and
when I'm thinking about that we get
number one in a second but when I'm
thinking about uh title and thumbnail um
that helps you with just again so much
Clarity around crafting a title before
you press record that's going to lead to
clicks and Views and success there so
people say okay if I how do I write good
titles that's something to master how do
I make good thumbnails that get people
to click that's something to master but
there's something more important than
all of that and that's usually the only
thing that gets brought up in in
conversation okay so what's in first
place if tags is fit F description is
fourth title is third thumbnail is
second what's in first place topic topic
is in first place and here's why because
the Creator who understands the viewer
best wins and if you wrote the best
title possible these days there's AI
tools and so you're like help me write a
great title about X you know you write a
great title if you designed the most
amazing thumbnail uh as possible like
you hired a graphic design designer you
paid him $500 for the thumbnail you
hired a writer who's a famous novelist
you paid him $500 for the title okay you
know well if it's about a topic that is
not what's top of mind for people a
topic that people aren't super
interested in a topic that isn't
actually like a pain point or a high
desire here's what I like to do I like
to actually score topics on a scale from
1 to 10 how interested are people in
this topic is it a one they're not that
interested like it's information they
may want to know but they're not that
interested is it a 10 it's the problem
they're worrying about every night if
you're looking to get your first th000
subscribers or make your first $1,000 on
YouTube then join our free YouTube
challenge that many other small creators
have joined and seen tons of success
during this free challenge Sean is going
to share some of the best strategies for
growing to your first 1,000 subscribers
on YouTube as well as making your first
$1,000 just go to tube 1K challenge.com
or check the link down in the
description it's their MO their highest
ambition it's one of their biggest
problems it's troubling them it's
causing conflict in their relationships
it's one of their desires and if you
think about the topic being a 10 even if
this is what's Wild even if the title is
not great the thumbnail is okay again
tags almost have no weight anymore but
there's some practicalities to them
description like topic is just such such
a big deal and if you talk about the
right Topic at the right time look at
anybody that covers trending news or
something that is Timely in the moment
the thumbnail might be terrible like all
they did was get a few things in the
title right uh to at least you just know
what it's about but the fact that you
wanted that information right now that
story right now so I think it's about
topics and let me apply some of the
topics I would do to my biohacking
channel so on my biohacking channel um I
would do product reviews again uh I love
these we call it RSP review specific
products because there are products that
help you I am personally a shopper I've
purchased red light therapy uh panels I
love them I would review them talk about
my experience but there's also a reason
I would do this because it would add
value it it notice we got our Clarity
right and I picked a topic that is
related a channel topic that is related
to products like if you're going to
biohack you can do a lot of you could
get into the sun you could go into a
cold River to cold plunge you could do a
lot of things that are natural but
there's also a lot of things which those
are great videos too but there's also a
lot of things that are purchasable
products that that don't just serve the
viewer but are also monetizable from the
start so so I could review specific
products tapen in like affiliate
marketing I would do interviews so again
I'm not actually really that big of an
expert I'm just the Curious student that
almost would act like a reporter to
curate the experts I love the interview
model because it allows me to just learn
more ask questions that I have and
here's what I'm you don't need to be a
product review Channel you need to be an
interview Channel we actually teach 16
different kind of topics video
categories that are very powerful for
getting views interviews is one of them
review specific products is one of them
but I'd be picking topics and what I
love about again interviews is probably
not at the start I wouldn't be able to
get somebody like Dave aspey who's Big
in the biohacking space or I wouldn't be
able to not at the start but you could
start like interviewing different
different people I I use what's called a
pfm pulse Electric magnetic field um
there's all these things about recovery
how what it can do for your body all
these benefits and I discovered a guy
named Dr Pollock who's kind of like the
leading expert he wrote a book he also
has an e-commerce store he also has an
affiliate program before any of that I
went with personal need I wanted to feel
better there were some chronic health
things um it's a very Niche product a
niche category but I don't have this
channel but I have a feeling someone
like Dr Paul he has like 5,000 Subs on
his YouTube channel I think he'd agree
to interview with me and and I could
jump on using a tool like streamyard or
something like that and interview
somebody who could go deeper there's
there's endless opportunities in the
biohacking world to do that so I'm now
creating leverage that's one form of
content I could go to the products that
are already in my house because I'm
living this and that's why if you pick
the right channel topic you should
already have the stuff because that's
who you are that's what you already are
into that's what you love and now you're
able to cash in on your passion you're
able to monetize your passion and uh I
would answer specific questions um
related to um biohacking maybe you know
how do you get better sleep or is
melatonin good for you or bad for you
and I may I actually would need to
probably do a lot of interviews to get
some of that information but then I also
um would teach specific skills maybe
things I've learned how to do here's how
you uh here's the routine that I have I
might do morning routine videos so we we
that's that topic is a topic for another
time um but I think picking the right
topics is going to be so key to getting
views picking the right channel topic
and picking the Right video topics and
the last thing I'll say on this one is
there's really kind of two big
categories of content there's
search-based content and there's
suggested content let me try to Define
search-based content what's powerful
here is
Biomax red light therapy 900x or
whatever model panels reviewed so what I
love about this is the reason I love
product review videos and is because
because products are influencers people
are listening to this right Sean I'm at
zero I'm starting from scratch how do I
get discovered and yeah and people don't
know you and people are not searching
for you and they're not looking for you
and why would they because they don't
know you yet and you Fe you're in
obscurity so what you want to be asking
if you're starting a channel from
scratch is how can I tap into influence
that's greater than my own most people
think I wish somebody famous would shout
me out I wish I could get a famous
interview well of course that's one
thing that would be helpful and that's
another reason why interviews are are
great form of content but people don't
realize that products are influencers
one of the ways I grew my brand was I
talked about particular camera models
you didn't know Sean Kell yet you knew
you were looking for a review or
comparison of the Canon 60D you found
that video you saw that that was my
experience video you know teaching how
to use cameras the best lenses and then
some level of connection happened there
and the influential thing was a
search-based topic was something that
somebody was looking for so I I actually
starting a channel from scratch and even
for established creators that want to
continue to grow I would not ignore a
search based content in a suggested
world and I'll explain what that is
briefly but search based content is
actually kind of a forgotten art and
it's probably one of the biggest
opportunities for people in
2024 but then the other option is
suggested so if the title of a search
based video is you know tutorial or
review um of a Biomax red light therapy
light a suggested title might be like
this weird
Gadget
supercharges your brain and it's a c
like that's not search-based because you
didn't wake up and be like is there a
weird Gadget that supercharges my brain
but we all see YouTube videos like that
that's your biggest shot for going
getting you know more kind of viral
content you're going for mystery
curiosity the thumbnails like what is
the gadget they maybe see it you're
you're you're doing that kind of thing
and and what I've seen is there's
extremes people usually pick one of the
other when the superpowers to
potentially do both the other superpower
is realizing that videos titled properly
can kind of also tap tap into to both um
and so red light therapy benefits pros
and cons of red light therapy dangers of
red light therapy that's a little more
search based but you also might be like
warning stop using red light therapy
panels immediately dot dot dot and so
that actually could be searched like
maybe somebody types in red light
therapy they actually find that because
it's and then you take it down the
direction like again you don't want to
clickbait but there is something about
mastering marketing mastering human
psychology and and those are some of the
skills you want to learn and and maybe
you you're in the video you're like
listen you need to stop using red light
therapy if you don't want to feel
awesome and amazing and you're like oh
you kind of TR yeah I thought you were
going to say dangers yeah if you just
you know so so I think M so so anyways
topics learning how YouTube Works
tapping into the power search based
content that's also what I would focus
on heavily if I was starting and it's if
there's one of it's easier I would argue
it's easier than suggested just meaning
if you are still developing your
charisma your skills you're nervous to
get on camera you're still just getting
started we have so many students who
have filmed videos on the worst camera
ever it's like they're filming on a
baked potato it's like a horrible webcam
in a poorly lit office the shot
composition is bad the audio in the room
is echoey they their hands are glued to
their sides and they're like they and
and we've also watched them transform
over months and years but even when they
start that way if they have good
information and they are really clear on
that how that information is going to
help somebody we've seen videos with
300,000 views because they got their
topic right and they put good
information behind it because it was
searching for a particular pain point
and again suggested may not be suggested
you may not go as viral if the video is
you know kind of boring I mean make it a
goal to not be boring but there's plenty
of kind of practical videos that are
pretty boring that still get millions of
views just because they're helpful and
people will endure it and it allows you
to actually grow get views maybe even
start making money while you're also
developing your skills so anyways we've
said a lot but yeah number four pick the
right topics Master coming up with the
right video topics for your audience tap
into search base tap into suggested and
definitely subscribe and stick around
because that's um you know we have a lot
on that yes we talk a lot about pain
points so problem and solution your
channel should identify a problem and
I'd also present the solution and every
video should do that as well and so no
matter what like channel topic video
topic we always recommend that people
think about problem and solution right
which is why you're saying like that
search-based content is really going to
be the where the money is for most
people starting a new channel and so um
as we get into our last point point I
would just say Sean that all of these
topics you you mentioned there's 16
different video like types that we go
through and that we teach people each
one of those you could do have one pain
point and you come at it six different
16 different ways so there's so many
different ways to tackle one topic and
one pain point and we do talk through
all of that inside of our course thean
Academy and so going deep into each one
of those and the structure of each one
of those videos is something that we can
like walk people through as well as
picking a right topic and all actually
every one of these points we could go
deeper in inside of our course and so um
I think we'll have like a link in that
if anybody wants to check it out but you
take us into Point number five yes okay
so number one courage start messy number
two Clarity gets you know get clear on
who and what who's your channel for what
problem does it solve one video per week
or just get your schedule dialed in
topics and then finally if I'm starting
a channel from scratch extreme Focus
that's my number five extreme focus and
I learned this the hard way so this kind
of makes me think about my Journey on
YouTube the first channel I started was
in 2007 from my church that was pretty
focused because that was the only
Channel I was doing and it was a clear
reason that by the way back to Clarity
actually was clear what we were trying
to do with it like give people a away to
watch the sermons upload you know
different videos we had it was so early
YouTube too we weren't really doing much
strategic but it was kind of like a
resource a way to send the videos out
email videos really early days but then
as I started to get into starting my own
channels I started my personal Channel I
started a Clear Vision media channel for
my business which is like a portfolio of
my video production business then I
started a channel called think
International with my friend Jeff Morris
which was like a faith-based channel
interviewing pastors and leaders and
authors uh kind of in the Christian
world and out of think International I
started getting questions about cameras
and what gear we were using to produce
those videos my background had been by
that time in video for about 7 years
video production so that led to the
start of think media um you know fast
forward a few years later and I started
a a side project with my friend video
infu uh with my friend Benji called
video influencers but here's what we
just like listed out I would say that
maybe around
2015 um I was trying to actually
simultaneously run all four of those
channels I
was still cting with Jeff every so often
we'd go to like a Christian Conference
and interview a few people I still did
some video production jobs so I'd upload
those in my portfolio I wanted to Vlog
when I could and Vlog a trip that I was
on so I uploaded that on like my Sean
kenel Channel I wanted to be consistent
on think media and then eventually uh
because I up to that point had so much
YouTube experience we started video
influencers to kind of collect our
learnings um and ramp up to a book we
eventually wanted to write so here's
what I'm saying I was was doing way too
much and that was not the only thing I
was doing my life is just as complex as
anybody else's I mean I know people
listen to this it's like you got stuff
to do you might have got kids you got
school you got work you're busy and when
I think about extreme Focus I think that
the problem is if you try and Chase four
rabbits you'll end up catching none of
them or you'll just be so tired and
fatigued and you'll delay your eventual
success because you've diluted your
energy in four directions you could have
compounded it in one so I think there's
a couple mistakes that people make when
starting a YouTube channel they maybe
get an idea they have a topic but if
you're listening to this you're probably
like me you're creative you have new
ideas every day you might have new ideas
for YouTube channels every day new
businesses New Opportunities you see you
might be like oh I should talk about AI
oh I actually I want to start a bone
broth company what I want to you know
start doing a book A book club I want to
write a book I want to write an ebook
and that's as I spin off and that's not
just YouTube because if you're listening
to this too you're like maybe I want to
create an online course when am I
starting my merch line how do I start my
patreon how do I slow down take a breath
extreme Focus coming from the person who
CH just tried to do it all it led to
more fatigue and I'm so grateful that
all those learnings and pain points
ultimately got me to where I am today
and I'm very grateful to be here but one
of our company missions is to shorten
people's learning curve we just want to
help you avoid the pain and the
heartache and the fatigue and and for
some um chasing too many rabbits might
lead to so much exhaustion so much
discouragement so much burnout that
would have been avoidable if you guarded
your focus so I've heard Focus stands
for this follow one course until
successful Focus follow one course until
tell successful what's the one channel
you're focusing on what's the one brand
You're Building what's the one business
you're building and I'm actually pretty
stunned and I know that maybe at least
half people listening to this though
they're they from they want to start
from scratch but they want to start
three channels because they're like man
I got so many passions but now that I've
thought about how like the channel
should have a clear who and a clear what
well the answer must be then to just
divide the things I want to talk about
it on three channels and I would
challenge you that that would be an
answer for organization but that's not
the best solution for your sanity your
success and your momentum if you had to
pick one pick one
it's hard enough to make one business
successful why are you trying to make
two businesses successful it's hard
enough to make one marriage successful I
guess if you're into polygamy it's why
are you trying to make three marriages
successful I don't know what people got
going on or three it's hard enough to
make one wife happy why you trying to
make that's my wife Sonia actually
always uh she's kind of into the
polygamy shows you know Sister Wives and
stuff like that and she she's always
she's like I just can't even imagine the
Dynamics but but all these different
things it's like yo you should pick one
you know uh Focus you know uh I actually
heard Dr Phil put it this way and I mean
I'm just quoting him here but this is
the way he said he said it he said God
gave you one ass so pick a horse and
ride it you can't ride two horses like
get and so God gave you one butt one
rare end pick your horse and let's just
go a little bit deeper on this I think
the other thing though if I'm starting a
YouTube channel from scratch I'm also
want to be hyper aware that I I want to
say this 2024 Public Enemy Number One is
distraction and in 2024 we got more
noise coming at us than ever before
there's more side quests on Instagram
and distractions and more ads coming at
you that you could be hit by and more
business opportunities because even as
you're starting a YouTube channel again
you're like oh what there's like new
tools to make my merch which yes like
eventually you could could make merch
and you could get your T-shirt going and
and you're on day one and you're like
should I use patreon or should I use
YouTube channel memberships on day one
neither you should start get one video
up a week make sure your topics are good
get clear and like be consistent because
you don't even have enough momentum yet
to be like worrying about the full
Business Development I'm not saying put
that in your business plan it's great to
have Clarity of at least the general
direction of the best ways to monetize
your particular Niche but people get so
distracted by so many different things
and it delays success at best it delays
success at worst it just wears you down
too much you can't think clearly you got
noise coming out you you're also you're
maybe watching too much content on
YouTube you're watching too many experts
you're reading too many books you're
buying too many books these are like all
things that I that I've done myself
you're you're going too many directions
at once let's make 2024 entirely
different you want to start a successful
YouTube channel I would challenge you to
to narrow the scope of even who you're
learning from many people have many
different Paths of how to get to a
particular objective but like pick one
like pick pick an expert pick a system
and work that system there's a famous
military quote that says a good plan
violently executed this week is better
than the perfect plan executed next week
There's Something about having a
maniacal sense of urgency but also a
maniacal sense of focus extreme Focus
because because there's so you know I
want to get in shape so what am I going
to do follow four personal trainers this
actually is a challenge that I have I
have my network of relationships in like
these different business groups I'm in
and whatnot and I'm fortunate and the
students that we coach and we coach a
lot of people in Fitness and oftentimes
people come to me and be like Sean you
know V video raet Academy the team
Melissa like you guys have just
transformed my life I'm so grateful I
would love to like coach you for free I
know you have a goal of getting in shape
or I'd love to give you a discount or
I'd love to give you this and I'm like
okay cool cool but then here's the
problem is I got this person that they
have a methodology that they're willing
to do that I have another guy over here
that he's willing to help me and then I
have another thing over here and I
actually have a personal trainer that I
hired here in Vegas and I got another
and everyone's a shiny object here's
what's interesting if I actually just
work out a little bit and do the
stretching and work a diet plan it
doesn't have to be the perfect if I just
work one of them then I'm going to get
more results than actually being
overwhelmed my brain shuts down and then
I end up doing nothing and I I hope that
people can really they're probably
feeling that like this is too real in a
2024 World and it's not that eventually
you can't continue to sharpen your skill
set like man I really learned this
methodology in 2024 and I mastered it
like I've heard people say they brag
about I read a book a week I read 52
books in 2024 that's some people's goals
I want to challenge you maybe change
that what if you only read one big book
this year 52 times and mastered it what
if you so focused
like like the ultimate badge of honor is
not how much information you consumed
the badge of honor was how much
information you mastered and implemented
and applied so extreme Focus try to
narrow down your time your energy and
don't don't misunderstand me the one of
my favorite quotes is you could do
anything you want but you can't do
everything I think it was David Allen
who wrote a great prod uh get stuff done
productivity book but I actually expand
on that I would say you can do anything
you want but you can't do everything but
actually you can do everything just not
right now just not all at
once so if you start looking at starting
a YouTube channel from scratch right now
and start dreaming over the next 5 to 10
years it's been said that most people
overestimate how much they can do in a
year but they underestimate how much
they can do in 5 to 10 years so don't
overestimate how much you can actually
get done in
2024 Focus extreme Focus get this thing
moving and then know that okay after you
have your it's sequencing after you have
moved one two 3 four five I'm doing my
weekly video I'm clear I'm starting
messy I'm doing these certain topics
some momentum's building I'm investing
in myself I'm leveling up my skills okay
great it's been a great 12 months now
we're at a particular level now I also
have more Rhythm I'm not as overwhelmed
by this it's more of a routine now I
want to write a book great so now I'm
going to write after I got about 12
months into I'm going to start writing
my book okay maybe around year three and
timelines can change but just don't try
to do everything all at once I actually
have a dream of starting another Channel
interestingly enough I I would love to
start this health related Channel and
maybe I will and we've got a team of 30
people here at think media and we have
help but I actually am applying extreme
F I want to get back to my Sean Kel
Channel at some point maybe do a little
bit more behind the scenes maybe some
other stuff but even I am choosing in
2024 we're doing think me media we're
doing the think media podcast we have
two channel well you have two channels
Sean yeah and also three silver play
buttons a gold play button and 30 people
helping me so like it's a little bit of
a different season know the season that
you're in stay focused kill distractions
Public Enemy Number One in 2024 is
distractions the external distractions
and the internal distractions of you
doing too many projects too many things
all at once keep it simple and focus so
we got five point points for everybody
who's thinking about starting actually
who should be starting a YouTube channel
in 2024 and that is the first and
foremost on is Clarity we've got Clarity
or courage courage first and foremost
start messing you have to so we've got
courage Clarity strategy and systems
topic and focus and so with those five
points I just think the entire time I'm
listening that we can go so much deeper
in each one of those and there's so much
more that we can be teaching but we have
to go all the way back to that first
point it is just courage it's getting
started and it's filming your first
video and that really is the like the
action item the next step for everybody
who's watching is to just get that first
video under your belt um punch beer in
the face and press record as you always
say and then from there we can really
start to work on each of those next four
four points in over the next year so
after you do punch fear in the face
record that first video and it's time to
start digging into each of those next
four points Sean as you were going
through each one of them really all I
could think is like we have this like
the perfect bundle of courses that every
single one of those points it we have
courses and downloads and classes that
go through them on a deeper level we
actually just closed out like this
really big sale on it um but I I think
we should open it back up for people who
are watching just because again it's
like such good alignment so um we'll
have that for our podcast listeners at
think Medias sale.com we'll give you
guys again like access to that um sale
just for everyone who's listening and it
has we Sean talked about systems and
processes we have a checklist in there
that's like walks you through your
entire shoot day checklist that's really
like that's literally the system that
you need we have a course called Niche
Finder that talks through your channel
topic and so it really is like direct
alignment is as you're talking or
listening to Sean you're thinking I want
to learn more about this I really want
to get these things nailed down for 2024
that bu is going to address all those
questions for you and so think Medias
sale.com is going to be um a great next
step for a lot of people as well and
it's like I mean we were offering it at
a crazy discount I guess that's what
we're going to offer for everybody
watching now too so it's just a really
good opportunity to jump in get started
on some deeper learning thanks for
listening to this episode uh make sure
you like rate the podcast give us a
review and we'll see you on the next one